BACK ON TRACK.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
RESULTS OUT OF ARIZONA AND
NEVADA.
FIRST NOW WITH MORE, HE HAD A
HUGE VICTORY IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA, FLORIDA SENATOR MARCO
RUBIO.
NEARLY 20% OF THE VOTE.
YOU COULD HAVE DONE BETTER.
I THINK YOU LET THE PARTY DOWN.
>> HA-HA-HA.
WE TRIED OUR BEST.
WE WERE OUTRAISED 2-1, AND WON
FLORIDA MORE THAN SCHUMER WON
NEW YORK.
WE'RE PROUD OF THE RACE.
PEOPLE WORKED VERY HARD.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IT JUST
SHOWS YOU A COUPLE THINGS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT ONE OF THEM.
THAT IS THE CHANGES WE'RE SEEING
IN FLORIDA.
THE CHANGES IN FLORIDA AREN'T
PEOPLE MOVING, BUT THAT'S
CERTAINLY TRUE, PEOPLE ARE
MOVING HERE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
GET AWAY FROM LUNACY IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY, BUT THE
OTHER CHANGE IS HAPPENING TO
PEOPLE TRADITIONALLY NOT
IDENTIFYING WITH THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, PARTICULARLY WORKING
CLASS, SMALL BUSINESS-OWN
HISPANIC FAMILIES, WHO HAVE WON
SENSE, WHO DON'T WANT SCHOOLS
INDOCTRINATING THEIR KIDS, WHO
HAVE FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE WITH
SOCIALISM, LEFTISM, AND DON'T
WANT ANY PART OF IT IN THIS
COUNTRY, AND WANT TO LIVE IN A
SOCIETY GOVERNED BY LEADERS WITH
COMMON SENSE.
THE UN CLIMATE CONFERENCE
THEY'RE HAVING THIS WEEK,
CRIMINALS RUNNING THROUGH THE
STREETS.
YOU PUT THAT AHEAD OF THEM,
THEY'LL PUNISH YOU AT THE BALLOT
BOX.
WISH IT WAS HAPPENING IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING, AND THE ULTIMATE
PRICE WILL BE PAID BY OUR
COUNTRY.
THIS WILL MAKE THE DEMOCRATS
MORALED.
BIDEN IS SAYING HE WON'T CHANGE
ANYTHING.
THEY THINK THIS IS AN
AFFIRMATION, LICENSE FOR THEM TO
GO OUT AND BE CRAZIER THAN
THEY'VE EVER BEEN.
WE HAVE A BIG FIGHT AHEAD OF US.
>> Sean: 850 PEOPLE MOVING INTO
FLORIDA DAY AFTER DAY AFTER DAY,
AN ASTRONOMICAL FIGURE, SENATOR.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS, THERE'S
LITTLE DAMAGE LEFT IN THE WAKE
OF THAT, BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
LEAVING NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
PENNSYLVANIA, AND THEY'RE
GOING -- THEY TEND TO GO TO THE
EAST COAST OF FLORIDA.
THEN THE MIDWEST.
THAT'S WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN,
ILLINOIS, INDIANA.
THEY SEEM TO GO TO THE WEST
COAST OF FLORIDA.
I'VE BEEN ON BOTH COASTS OF
FLORIDA.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT MAKES THOSE
STATES HARDER FOR REPUBLICANS TO
WIN.
I THINK IT'S HAVING AN IMPACT ON
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
DO YOU SEE THAT?
>> IT IS.
LOOK, THAT'S A FACTOR.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE NUMBERS
ARE, BUT EVERY REPUBLICAN VOTER
THAT MOVES TO FLORIDA IS GREAT
FOR US.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY TAKING A VOTE
AWAY FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND SOMETHING.
LITERALLY EVERYTHING IN OUR
SOCIETY AND CULTURE IS ALIGNED
AGAINST REPUBLICANS.
VIRTUALLY EVERY MAJOR TELEVISION
AND MEDIA OUTLET IN AMERICA IS
AGAINST US.
ALL THE CELEBRITIES.
ALL THE MOVIE ACTORS.
I MEAN, YOU NAME IT.
IT'S JUST CONSTANT.
THE TECH COMPANIES.
NOW MAJOR AMERICAN CORPORATIONS.
IT'S AMAZING REPUBLICANS ARE
EVEN COMPETITIVE, UP LESS
WINNING THESE SEATS.
LOOK, I THINK WE'LL WIN THE
HOUSE.
WE STILL HAVE A CHANCE.
WE'LL WIN NEVADA.
I THINK ARIZONA.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
I HONESTLY THINK, LIKE YOU GUYS
ARE REPORTING, AND I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING AGAINST THE STATE OF
ARIZONA, GREAT PEOPLE, BUT SEEMS
LIKE YOU REPORTING ON A THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY, THAT'S HAVING AN
ELECTION, FINDING NEW VOTES HERE
OR THERE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THAT'S
POSSIBLE IN THE 21st CENTURY.
FLORIDA HAD EVERY VOTE
TABULATED.
WE KNEW HOW MANY VOTED BY 7:05,
8:05, AND THEY'RE ALREADY
REPORTING RESULTS IN MIAMI-DADE
COUNTY, ALMOST A MILLION VOTES
CAST HERE, BY 7:04.
I JUST DON'T GET IT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
>> Sean: YEAH.
IT'S WRONG.
IT'S UNFAIR TO THE PEOPLE IN
THOSE STATES.
IT'S ALSO UNFAIR TO THE PEOPLE
IN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
SENATOR, THIS WAS A MASSIVE WIN.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND TO
THE GOVERNOR.
JOB WELL DONE.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING T